[music]
Democrats placed just greater emphasis
on the public health aspects of the crisis
while Republicans tended to talk about
more generalized national unity.
Republicans were placing a greater emphasis on China
and also sort of mobilizing the country
in sort of combative terms.
We're gonna
fight coronavirus and beat coronavirus.
The word coronavirus is
disproportionately used by Republicans.
[music]
We started the timeline for this data at
the first explicit mention of coronavirus,
which is January 17th, and
then we let it run up until the end of March.
We have this dictionary that we
use to flag terms.
Even down to the hashtags that the parties tended to use.
We specified a machine learning algorithm
to look at the relationship between
different term usage and partisanship
among a certain set of tweets.
The sort of three-quarters-ish level of accuracy
that we got is similar to
what's been observed elsewhere--in floor speeches.
We take that level of
out-of-sample classification accuracy
and that ability to correctly identify
the partisanship of who said what.
[music]
Even people who are well aware
of what the scientific consensus is on an issue
may reject that consensus
if it becomes an issue that
implicates their cultural identity.
Citizens were being asked to be
an active participant in the public's response.
So it's particularly important
that things like wearing a mask or not going to bars
don't become cultural signifiers
that implicate your political identities.
[music]
We have planned analysis to look at
similar patterns on governors
who we think might be less polarized.
We don't have Trump tweets in there.
Trump's tweets are obviously important.
What is happening at the presidential election level with Trump and Biden.
There are a lot of smart of people thinking about this now.
So I'm sure we'll start to see
really--really interesting stuff coming out soon.
[music]